[Music]
sarah's kicking us off in denver sarah
welcome to the show
hey thanks for having me huge fan of
yours of ken's probably right you meant
ken
george she laughed nervously sure i did
that's great sarah how can we help today
yeah so i'm actually traveling on a
business trip right now and i've been
going through dave's baby steps um don't
have a credit card i'm 1800 away from
being out of debt fully so really
excited about that awesome um on this
work trip i kind of had the worst
nightmare flight situation last night
where everything was canceled had to do
a hotel and the connection flight was
only two hours it's a two-hour drive
away so my boss was like we're going to
cancel that grab a rental car take it
from there to that city and then just
drop it back off at the
supposed to be city i'm in airport so we
were going through that and the rental
car company was saying because i had a
debit card
they rejected me because the drop-off
location was different
and my boss who knows i don't have a
credit card was like
very frustrated because i don't have a
company card which as of today i do
through this situation
um but he couldn't authorize it and it
kind of then i had to uber from that
city like it turned out to be a very big
fiasco
so i guess my question is unfortunately
now i have a company card and defended
why i don't have a credit card to my
boss and was like this is work you
should give me this anyway rather than
expense it but has this been a personal
situation just happening to me and i
didn't have one
um is it worth it to get a card if this
happens rather than have to pay more
fees to uber everywhere
well you're seeing it as a binary option
of either i uber everywhere or i have to
get a credit card i don't see it that
way personally because and that's from
personal experience so i i understand
and i agree that it is not a fun
situation for a lot of folks right now
trying to rent a car with a debit card
there are some things you have to be uh
prepared for you got to be intentional
about researching hey what are the
companies debit card policies with you
know who i'm booking with so for example
i rent i rented with enterprise recently
and they allow debit cards they're just
a 20 hold of your total amount that goes
on the card
and so what i want you to do is just do
that research
i've normally done that because that's
why i did it for this flight it was
actually with enterprise as well but
they just said because the drop-off city
was different they didn't allow it oh
interesting so with that specific policy
yeah i mean i would start to research
different companies and see what their
policies are on different drop-off
locations because normally you're
probably dropping off at the same
location correct
correct okay so i don't want to make a
decision based off a one-off weird fluke
thing and i i mean it sounds super
frustrating i'm sorry you went through
that but i don't also don't want you to
go get a credit card just for
this one instance and go well it didn't
work this one time so i'm gonna go down
this path yeah sarah look look it sucks
right
but this isn't gonna happen very often
when it does you had an alternative and
you may not have liked it you may have
spent a little bit more money on the
uber but again this is a rare situation
and george is absolutely right if you go
get the credit card for this
really
rare situation
you're just creating a temptation to
actually use it and so you believe in
the principles
remind yourself why you believe in the
principles and also be able to step back
for this and go yes this was a really
nightmarish situation but the reality is
it doesn't happen very often
it did happen
and
two things that i can walk away with
that
convince me i don't need a credit card
number one your boss gave you a company
card so now this isn't gonna be an issue
anymore
period on a personal level
could this scenario happen again yes but
what would you do well you've got cash
and you've got
a debit card and you can uber it's not
the end of the world you can get where
you need to go so don't convince
yourself that you need to do something
that you don't believe in
for this rare situation yeah and if
you're going on a trip with friends if
that situation comes up usually your
friends are going all right i got the
credit card all right sweet you book it
i'll venmo you the amount you know if
you're splitting the booking in a
situation like that so there's ways
around it with other people but i get it
if you're doing the ramsey plan ken this
is one of those things where you go oh
gosh how am i gonna navigate this but a
lot of people don't realize that there's
other ways around it when you don't back
yourself into a corner and go well
there's only these two options i
actually have a question for you
have you done an analysis or are you
just aware of
the difference between a rental car
because rental car costs have gone up if
i'm not mistaken versus getting an uber
so let's say i land in any city what's
the difference between ubering versus uh
certainly it's gonna be more it depends
on the city you're going to and where
you're trying to head to is it a huge
discrepancy it can't be so for example
me and my wife who went to san francisco
and you know transportation there we
just decided to do ubers instead of
getting a rental car because i didn't
want the hassle of driving around the
city yeah and it was significantly
cheaper than if we had rented a car
right
and i actually prefer the uber i got to
tell you i don't want to i don't want to
deal with i want to relax on vacation i
want someone else to drive me i don't
like driving period ken's got to shut up
much less no i don't
it's me it's me guys i'm kidding